this was a significant victory for the
duchess of sussex in an increasingly
bitter dispute with the court of appeal
rejecting attempts by the mail on sunday
to take their privacy battle to trial it
prompted an extraordinary statement from
the duchess taking aim at the tabloid
industry as a whole
while this win is precedent setting what
matters most she said is that we are now
collectively brave enough to reshape a
tabloid industry that conditions people
to be cruel and profits from the lies
and pain that they create adding these
harmful practices don't happen once in a
blue moon they are a daily fail that
divide us and we all deserve better
she also accused the paper of deception
intimidation and calculated attacks but
some within the industry say change will
be hard to come by
everyone thinks this sort of tabloid
culture is something to do with our age
it's not it's sort of 300
years of the british writing about the
royal family and wondering about their
relations
you know and how they get on with each
other that level of interest isn't going
to go away
the case centered on the publication of
parts of a letter megan sent to her
estranged father thomas markle in august
2018 she sued the paper's publisher for
breach of privacy and copyright with the
high court ruling in her favor without a
trial the court of appeal agreed based
on how much of the letter was published
whilst it might have been proportionate
to publish a very small part of the
letter for that purpose it was not
necessary to publish
half the contents
of the five-page letter as associated
newspapers had done
evidence heard here last month that
megan wrote that letter to her father in
the knowledge that it could be leaked
was seen as potentially explosive but as
it happened the court of appeal said it
found that new evidence to be of little
assistance it also disregarded the
matter which prompted an apology from
the duchess for misleading the court she
forgot how information about her was
passed to the authors of an unauthorized
biography the reporting of which privacy
campaigners say is proof the press needs
reforming there are deep problems here
this is about this was never a story
about the conduct of the duchess
but the public was told it was a court
case about the conduct of the duchess
and and that was dishonest from the
start
that's why a lot of people might be
surprised by this outcome
but the legal battle may not be over yet
associated newspapers limited say
they're disappointed at the ruling and
are considering an appeal to the supreme
court iva bennett sky news